un camp de migrants va-t-il être
installés ici à louveciennes la rumeur
enfle depuis plusieurs jours la
préfecture des yvelines a ciblé
plusieurs sites sur le département dont
la plaine de villevayre pour accueillir
une centaine de migrants
le lieu en question est un ancien pôle
industriel de 24 hectares actuellement
en friche situé à proximité de cette
discothèque et du triangle de
rocquencourt une nouvelle est une façon
de faire qui agace le maire de la
commune
c'est toujours si vous voulez embêtant
enfin je veux dire
agaçant pour pas dire fortement
irritants d'apprendre les choses par par
là par les médias et que les maires qui
sont quand même le premier niveau de
démocratie démocratie locale n'ait pas
été informé j'ai été irrité par le fait
qu'on puisse nous imposer que l'état
puisse nous imposer des choses que nous
n'avons sur lesquels nous n'avons pas
été concertés
une nouvelle qui préoccupe également le
front national la section départementale
du parti de marine le pen a organisé
hier un rassemblement devant la mairie
de versailles
nous ce qu'on dénonce c'est de manière
générale
l'immigration illégale et maintenant
quelle sûr que cette immigration
illégale
ce s'installe dans les yvelines c'est
déplorable
effectivement pour les yvelines et pour
les habitants dvd en tant que j'aurai
départementale des yvelines c'est de mon
devoir de le dénoncer
selon la préfecture des yvelines aucune
date ni aucun lieu précis n'ont été
retenu à ce jour